well I have made it to the city of love
and here is a crazy story for you I've
just been on a surfing trip that's why
I'm dressed for the beach not for Paris
a nation Geographic called me and they
said you need to cut your surfing trip
short and come to Paris to interview
president macron for the one Planet
polar Summit so here I am in the city of
love not to get engaged but instead to
talk with the president and leading
scientists uh about icebergs and very
lovely cold
[Music]
places
turns out you can't go and meet a
president in your flip-flops so it's
time to get
changed now I got to remember to tie a
tie send help okay tie complete got
dolphins on it very on brand National
Geographic okay I think we're ready
let's do this well here we go here at
the Natural History Museum in Paris for
the one Planet polar Summit and I'm glad
to not be wearing flip-flops anymore
yeah excited as a wildlife filmmaker I'm
always looking for new ways to make a
positive impact so to speak with
president macron was a real honor and an
exciting opportunity especially as he is
vocal about finding Global solutions to
The Climate
[Music]
crisis my name is berti Gregory I'm a
wild filmmaker with National Geographic
and very good thanks i' just like to
start by showing you a quick video a
very special group of Antarctic Kow
whales that use teamwork to create waves
to wash seals off the ice so these seals
would otherwise be Out Of Reach for
these kilow whales but together they
create waves to wash the seals into the
water these Kow whales are in trouble
there's only 100 of them in existence
and they're declining because their SE
ice home is is disappearing I've seen
many world leaders talk about the
environment and I don't always believe
that they genuinely care but when I
watch you I get the impression that you
do genuinely care and so I'm curious to
know where does your passion your love
for the en environment come from how did
that originate look I I'm I I'm
converted no no but sincerely I was not
initially as a politician I worked very
hard on Africa and different countries
and I was shocked by how much climate
change and crisis of biodiversity is
impacting first most vulnerable
countries and poor and emerging
countries you cannot build something
strong in an unfair World second I don't
believe for our children that we will
build something sustainable if we don't
care
human dignity is number one but Humanity
cannot survive without
biodiversity and sustainable climate and
for his scold political strategy I
expected this spot right here to be full
of ice not just icebergs but sea ice
this whole area Frozen and it's not this
year is different you've been very good
at positioning France as a world leader
in the conversation with climate crisis
and protecting polar regions we're
having a discussion but we're much more
interested in the doing so I'm curious
to know how do you envision France's
role in in protecting these polar
regions and fighting climate crisis what
we want to do is to fight for cryosphere
glaas poles and so on so the first way
to do it is to protect our own place one
100% of our glasses are already
protected but just
60% have the high level of protection so
we will go from 60% to 100% second we
build this Coalition precisely to engage
a lot of countries to work with us on
Research we have to launch a big
research program to push countries to
make action I decided to invest 1
billion on our polar strategy for Arctic
and Antarctic so here are a few examples
of the very clear commitments research
protection and so on sea ice has been
steadily disappearing over the last
decade you might think this place looks
cold but Antarctica is one of the
fastest warming regions on Earth this
issue is is bigger than France it
requires a huge amount of global
cooperation how are you going to bring
all these countries together I think the
main message was to say cryosphere is
already address and this is a big issue
for all of us tomorrow it will be your
problem as well so this is a scientific
discussion scientific cooperation and
this is where it's important to
work beyond the craziness of this time
with all the different big Powers now
the critical points and where we would
have to put pressure is about
conservation and
preservation we have to decarbonize we
have to be compliant with Paris
agreement this is a multi crisis with
multi impacts and we have to follow up
on all these STS but it's very important
to remain committed on biodiversity and
climate change and to be sure that we
engage with all the big Powers so it's
just matter of action I know that I
don't believe their for ever and I will
have to explain what did I do during
this period of time so I don't want to
be to have decayed of my life saying I'm
I'm sorry I didn't know it's it's not
true right we did know I just want to
explain what we did cool well thank you
very much for your time thank you so
much by the way I'm a big fan cool
thanks very much well that's cool the
president is a fan but I'm still waiting
for the followback on
Instagram but seriously talking to him
furthered my insight into the climate
crisis from policy level and it's
motivated me to carry these learnings
back into the field and continue
documenting the changes in our most
remote
places crucially this event is not just
about world leaders it's about the
scientists the key people who are
gathering important data they are the
ones who are pushing us forwards and
finding innovative solutions for the
planet what happens in Antarctica
doesn't stay in Antarctica we estimate
that there is a the PO potential of
instability that could be a Tipping
Point and with no return and so this
vessel is going to be frozen into the
ice drifting slowly around Pack full of
scientists and some cool technology what
do you hope it will achieve a common
understanding of the Artic with all the
nations around and of course to also to
tell people and to share this adventure
I mean we need we to show people with
emotion and enited to do this for the
next 20 years why should people that
live far away from these places care
because because what happens to the
world's ice is what happens to the
planet but we have to act now but it
does require the people demanding this
and not because of polar bears but
because it impacts their
lives I think events like these are so
important because they bring together
leading scientists and world leaders to
come together to really figure out how
we're going to fix the climate crisis
and restore the health of polar regions
and many world leaders have spent a lot
of time talking the talk about these
things now it's time for them to walk
the walk well time to say goodbye to the
amazing Southern right well and that's a
wrap for the one Planet polar
[Music]
Summit